Today is Friday.
Happy Friday, everybody.
Hope you have a great weekend.
Friday is usually when
I catch up
on some personal stuff,
you know.
I check my inbox,
of course, on Fridays.
I return some e-mails,
and of course,
I write out thank you notes.
Well, I was running --
I was running a bit late --
running behind today.
What's that?
-You were really
running behind today?
-Yeah, I was running
behind today,
so I just didn't get around
to doing my thank you notes.
-What were you doing?
-Oh, I was, um...
I was teaching myself
new skateboard tricks
with those finger skateboards,
remember that?
So -- Hours.
-Hours.
-Yeah, I mastered it.
-Ollie, Ollie!
Ollie. Yeah.
I was just wondering if you guys
wouldn't mind --
could I write out my weekly
thank you notes right now?
Is that --
I'll take that as a yes.
James can I get some thank you
note-writing music, please?
♪♪
Thank you, "Loki" poster,
For looking like
you were designed by someone
who got their start
making ransom notes.
"Meet me at the docks
at midnight?"
-Loki.
♪♪
Thank you, Lucky Charms,
for partnering with Marvel
to release Loki Charms.
Although personally,
I can't wait for Groot Loops.
-Nice one. Nice one.
-Groot Loops.
-Very nice.
♪♪
Thank you, "The Bachelorette",
for being a show
where a bunch of guys show
you exactly why they're single.
No.
"Hi, I'm Tad G,
I'm an entrepreneur."
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-Yeah
-You, too?
-You, too? All of you?
-All of us are entrepreneurs.
-And you only share five names.
That's a good --
-Yeah, we went --
This is the Tad season.
-Yeah.
-You must be talking about
Tad D.
-No, Tad J. I was talking about.
-The entrepreneur?
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah, you're right.
That is Tad J.
-Yeah, that's him, bro.
♪♪
Thank you
"Springsteen on Broadway" --
coming back!
For being one of the best
shows to get tickets for
and the worst show
to be an understudy for.
"Ladies and gentlemen, tonight,
the role of Bruce Springsteen
will be played by Terry."
-Hey!
One, two --
one, two, three and four.
♪ I grew up on
the streets of Jersey ♪
♪ And I didn't know much,
so I went to Mersey ♪
♪ And over in London
things were pretty hectic ♪
And -- I can't.
♪ Didn't expect it -- ♪
expect it?
♪ Didn't expect it. ♪
-Yeah, yeah.
-♪ You wanted Bruce,
but it's me, Terry ♪
♪ You didn't expect it ♪
Right?
-Yeah. Keep it going.
-Sure. Sure.
-Yeah.
Yeah, of course. Great.
Yeah, Jimmy you're great.
Jimmy, everything's cool.
What you did out there
rapping was so awesome.
Don't check the internet.
-Don't. Seriously, don't.
No --
-It was great.
-Give me your phone.
-It was so funny.
-Oh my God. I loved it.
-What you did -- that rap,
when you improvised,
oh, that just did --
That was so good.
Don't check the Internet.
Just stay away.
Stay away for the weekend.
Just stay away from it.
What do you care, right?
-Yeah.
-What do you care?
-What you did was interesting.
-Yes. I loved it.
I just want to say that.
-I've never -- I've seriously
never heard anything like it.
Like, I never heard anything
like it.
-Ever. Ever.
-Ever.
And I've been working
in the business for a long time
and I've never heard anything
like what you just did.
Don't check the Internet.
Don't read the --
Don't pick up the phone.
If anyone calls you,
don't pick it up.
-Yes.
-Why would you answer anything?
Just take the weekend. Get on --
Do you have a hammock?
Lay on --
-Do you have an island?
Do you have a place where you
get no reception?
-[ Laughs ]
And island?
-Yeah, an island
or something like that.
Just go there.
You know what I mean?
-Like, you have like a cave?
Is there a cave
you want to, like, explore?
Go spelunk.
-Spelunk, man.
-Dude, this is the weekend
for spelunking.
Go check out the cave
and just get in there man.
And don't get out
until Monday.
-You have any
Bose soundproof headsets?
-Yeah. How about the box
it came in?
Put the box over your head.
Don't look at anything,
don't listen to anything.
But what you did was --
[ Smooches ]
I mean -- Whatever that means,
you know.
Please don't -- Please
don't ever do it again.
You know, could be whatever.
-Yeah.
-Don't -- Don't try to replicate
it because it was...
mmm.
-No, I would say
don't do it again.
-Because --
-Because it was too --
-It was what it was.
-Yeah.
-And -- And if you
do it again, why?
You know.
-You did it.
-That's just my advice.
-You definitely --
You did --
You did it. [ Laughs ]
♪♪
Thank you, summer,
for being the time
we all reconnect
with our true best friends,
anyone who has a pool.
New pool.
♪♪
Thank you, everyone
being unsure about
when you're supposed to wear
a mask,
for insuring 2021 will be
the year of the chin swing.
Chin swing.
-We're good?
-Oh, I knew.
I'm wearing this for warmth.
-100%.
♪♪
Thank you, wedding invitations
for letting me
finally give my fridge what
it's always been missing --
a photo of my second cousin
holding hands with some dude
I've never met.
You guys look happy.
-Every day.
♪♪
Thank you, hockey,
for being invented
by someone who looked
at figure skating
and thought, "That's cool,
but could we add punching?"
Maybe?
♪♪
Thank you,
Philadelphia's naked bike ride
for being the one day a year
when people in Philly
show more crack
than the Liberty Bell.
There you have it.
Those are
the thank you notes.